[Music]
[Applause]
this of course is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
now so far after what like a year and a
half
many challengers no winners nobody has
actually caught us making a mistake yeah
unbelievable but they keep trying yeah
it's sad
well tonight a fan named matt thinks
that he has caught a mistake he says it
happened when i was talking to modern
families ty burrell and i imitated a
certain television character
hello conan in your interview with
modern families ty burrell he shows a
picture of himself with a mustache and
he jokingly says that he thought his
character could be like a ned flanders
type and then you replied with haidily
doodily i thought wouldn't it be funny
if phil had a mustache sort of ned
flandersy and i mean
yeah italy doodly homer yeah
that of course is incorrect on the
simpsons ned flanders is known for
saying how to lead italy
conan that's the most egregious mistake
yet considering that you were a writer
and producer on the simpsons for two
years
i got you
people think they got me this time don't
they yeah yeah you think i'm in trouble
this time don't you well guess what
matt if that's even your real name
it probably is your reaction why would
he lie about that who would make up that
name
matt you are dead wrong hadley doodly is
what ned flanders says on the simpsons
you think i'm wrong
why don't we ask ned flanders himself
please welcome the voice of ned flanders
the incomparable harry shearer
hey
so good to see you harry and i hate to
call you but this is important what is
the deal is it hayley doodley or
howdley dudely well uh this is actually
a very sad situation conan um and a
serious problem uh your your viewer matt
clearly suffers from what's known in the
medical profession as
hedley howdley displacement syndrome
or
hhds it's sometimes called h2ds you may
have heard that or hcs uh some are even
advocating h squared ds which makes no
sense to me but anyway okay so uh harry
i've never quite heard of this it sounds
like a terrible condition though
it's troublesome um and
here's what happens uh a sufferer will
hear ned flanders uh and think his brain
thinks he's hearing ned flanders saying
hardly doodle a neighbor
and
but the brain is misfiring what ned is
really saying is haley doodly neighbor
and it's there's no way to deal with
this now matt
i'm gonna speak to you directly uh this
is a serious problem
i'm gonna send you a pamphlet
it's all living with hayley howdley
displacement syndrome
we've taken the liberty of putting your
picture on it
now don't be under any misapprehension
matt there's not much hope for people
with your condition
but i'm sending you the pamphlet anyway
just to make myself feel better and um
we're also sending you this pamphlet so
harry shearer made a fool of you on
national television
good luck man
harry shearer thank you god bless
you everybody
[Laughter]
there are no curtains in animation
the hell is this thing where's the
microphone anyway the challenge still
stands if you think you spotted an error
on our show reported teamcoco.com
haha i found an error we will sort it
out right here on the air let's see if
you have what it takes to make chump
meat out of the maestro